- Hey, everyone, this is Luka,
I'm really excited to
tell you that my course
on The Basics of R for
Ecologists is up and running,
so if you're an ecologist
and you're just getting started with R
and feeling that frustration
of the learning curve
and just need something that
can take you by the hand
to really understand
the solid fundamentals
of using R for Ecology,
check out my course,
just go to RforEcology.com.
There's a link also down below
and hope to see you there.
(upbeat instrumental music)
Hey, everyone, it's Luka here.
I want to do a really quick video
showing you the essentials
of R for Ecology cheat sheet,
going through each one of the
functions on that cheat sheet,
which altogether probably
comprise about 80%
of every function you'll
ever need to use in R
as an ecologist or
biologist more generally.
So let's get started.
First we're just going to
create some data really quick
that we can use for demonstrating
all of these functions.
And there we have it.
So here we have a little
bit of data that we can use
to understand how these functions work.
So don't worry I'm gonna
include all of this code
down in the comments below,
or in the blog posts
that I'm gonna be posting
with this video,
so you can just copy and paste this
into the start of your code.
All right, now let's get to it.
So the first function is
probably the most common function
you'll ever need to know in R,
and that is the concatenate function
or just C function for short,
and this is for creating vectors.
So as we did above here
with number vector,
and so when we run number vector,
we get these values and we
can also create a vector
using character variables.
So here we have SPP one,
or species one, species three, species two
and species three.
And when we created this
and run species vector,
we have this vector of character values.
Okay, next we have sum.
So with sum, that simply adds up
all the different numbers
in a vector together.
So if we do sum num vec,
and run that, we get 20,
because three plus six plus
three plus eight is 20.
If we have an NA in these data,
so let's say we had a vector inside here
that contains everything in num vec,
but then also an NA
value or a missing value,
you'll actually get an NA because
by definition NA means you
don't know what that value is,
so because you don't know
what one of these values is,
you cannot actually calculate
the sum of all of these
and you get an NA.
However, you can add in an argument,
NA dot remove or NA dot RM equals true.
And when we run this, it ignores that NA
and sums everything else together.
Next, we have length.
This simply tells you either
the length of a vector,
or the number of columns in a data frame.
So for, if we do num vec in here,
we get four because there are
four elements in that vector.
If we look at this data
frame here that we created,
let's just take a look at it,
running that, we have
one column of num vec,
one column of species vec,
and this is the whole data frame together.
Now, if we run length for the data frame,
we get just the number of columns,
in this case, two columns.
All right, moving on.
Unique.
Unique tells us how many
unique elements there are
within a vector.
So for example, if we put
in number vec, or num vec,
we have a three, we have a
six and we have an eight.
And the reason we don't
have four values here
is because the three repeats itself twice.
Sometimes you want to know what the
total number of unique
values within a vector are.
And a simple way to do that,
let's say we want to know how
many unique species there are
inside species vec.
So let's put species vec in here.
And when we run that we get
these unique species IDs,
but let's say we had a really long list
and we can't just count that it's three,
we can actually use the length function
around the unique function,
and now we can find out
that there are three unique
different types of species
inside species vec.
All right, next, as dot numeric.
This is useful because sometimes
when you load data into R,
for whatever reason it turns a,
what should be a number vector
into, or a numeric vector
into a character vector.
So let's say for example,
we had a character vector,
actually, it was supposed
to be a number of vector,
but actually it somehow loaded into R as.
And the reason this can happen
is because I'll show you another example.
Let's say these are all numeric,
but then somewhere in your data,
your field assistant
entered in the letter O
instead of the number zero.
And so when you upload these data
and take a look at char vec,
it actually turns all of
these numbers into characters,
including that original O.
So if we use as dot
numeric, put that in there,
we'll get this warning message that says
NAs introduced by coercion
and that's because that O
isn't actually a real number.
In fact, it's not a fake number either.
It's not a number.
So we are left with these numbers here
three, five, two, one, five
and an NA value for
where that O used to be.
Next, we have the log function.
I'm not going to give a full example
of using the log function here.
Simply because we don't have a lot of data
for this quick demonstration,
but simply put this extracts
the natural logarithm
of a value or of the values in a vector.
So if we put in here,
let's just say the number
three and run that,
this is the natural
log of three, 1.098612.
If we have a vector values here, num vec,
it calculates the logarithm
of all of these numbers.
And this is useful usually
when you're visualizing
or plotting data that's skewed to one side
and you want to be able to
visualize it a little bit nicer
I find myself using log
function quite a bit.
And then you just have to
indicate on one of your axis
that the data are logged transformed.
Next we have the sort function.
This is used to arrange
a vector numerically
or alphabetically.
So if we have our num
vec here and run that,
it'll rearrange all the values in num vec,
starting with the lowest,
going up to the highest,
or if we do use our species vector,
it will organize them alphabetically.
And actually it also
organized them numerically
because SPP is the same
for all of these values,
but the one, two, three and three
was used for rearranging these values.
But if let's say we had a
bunch of different letters,
D S and A, if we run sort,
whoops, we actually need
to make that into a vector.
There we go.
Try that again.
It has rearranged them
with A starting first
then D and then S.
we can also reverse that order by saying,
so if we ran sort on num vec,
we get three, three, six, eight
and we can add in this argument,
decreasing equals true.
And now the values will be decreasing,
starting with eight, six, three and three.
Next we have this is dot NA function.
is dot NA is super useful.
I use it almost all the time,
because we're always encountering values
that might be a NA or missing.
Essentially what this does is it tells us
is a value an NA or not.
So if we add in a vector
here, let's make up,
let's make up a vector.
One, two, three, five,
there was no two. It's just
one, three, five NA, run that.
We get false, false, false, and true.
Because one, three and five
are not NA but NA is NA.
So we get a true there.
The reason this is useful is normally
for most other values we could say,
let's say we want to find out,
actually, let's create
this as a new vector.
We'll call it new vec.
And let's say,
we want to see which of these
values is greater than two.
So we'll say new vec is greater than two,
and we get a false, true, true, and NA
'cause we don't know what that value is.
The three and five are greater than two.
The one is less than two. So we get false.
Let's say we want to see which
values are equal to three.
We get false.
And then we get true for the
three, false and then NA,
that makes sense.
But now let's see if we want to find out
which values are NA.
So we put equals NA.
Ah, but look, we get four NAs,
that's because NA means
we don't know what it is.
So you can't actually
say new vec equals NA,
because that's like saying new
vec equals I don't know what.
So that's what we use this is dot NA for.
That's useful if you want to
identify which values are NA
and want to remove them
from your data set.
Oftentimes I'll use is dot
NA with an exclamation point
in front of it, which
actually makes it not.
So rather than giving you
false, false, false, true.
It reverses those by
applying this not statement.
And when you run that you
get true, true, true false.
So sometimes for example,
if you wanna remove NAs from a data set,
you can use this and index
your data using this.
So let's,
we'll actually use new
vec here instead of that
to make it a little simpler to see.
If we index new vec with
this true, true, true, false,
we are left with just one, three and five
and successfully removed
that NA value from our data.
All right, next,
we have the
in percent
in percent operator or
whatever that's called.
Not technically a function,
but super, super useful nonetheless.
Used for finding what items
match between two vectors.
Usually used for matching character values
between two vectors, but can
be used for numbers as well.
Let me show you how this works.
Let's use the example
from the cheat sheet.
Species vec in,
and let's create this
new vector species one
and species four.
So what this does is it says
here we've got species vector,
we've got this vector four different,
well, three different species,
but four different elements.
And then we have this other vector
of these two individuals here.
And what this says is within species vec,
which of these values are
also found inside this vector.
So when we run this, we get
true, false, false, false.
When we look at what species vector is,
the first value is species one,
which is found in this
vector, so that's true.
And species three, species
two and species three
are not found inside this vector.
So we get false, false,
false for each of those.
Now, if we reverse this
and run that we get true and false,
because again, species one
is found inside species vec
but species four is not.
So remember that whatever goes
before the percent in percent
is the vector for which you're
going to get trues and falses
to see whether these elements
also occur in this vector.
So next, we have a really
cool set of functions
for parsing date values.
Up until now, we've been
using the base package,
which comes installed with R,
we don't have to load any new packages,
but for this next function,
we're going to load
the Lubri date package.
If it's not installed already
use install dot packages Lubridate,
I have it installed already
so I'm not going to run that.
So I'm just going to run library
lubridate
to load that package.
So what lubridate gives us
is this really cool set of functions
that we can create
using a Y, an M and a D.
Y stands for year, M stands
for month, D stands for day.
So we can create a function Y month day,
we can say day, month, year,
we can say, year, day,
month, you get the idea.
You can do any combination of these three.
And so you want to order
the year, date and month
based on the date that
you are trying to parse.
So let's say we have,
let's say we somehow
entered in our field data,
the dates, as let's say,
2016 slash
June
comma
13.
Now this is just a character
value, nothing special,
no date object here,
but let's say all of our
data are in this format
and you're going, geez,
how am I going to make R know
that these are actually date values
and not some weird format
that I decided to use?
Well, we'll use this
function here in this case,
Y for year first, month
comes next, date comes last,
make sure this order is the same
as the order of values in
here and we run it and voila.
We now have a date object
where R knows that this is a date,
and we can tell that because
it's transformed this format
into this nice standard date format in R.
We can also save this
as an object, my date,
and take a look at that.
If you run the function class
and then put my date inside there,
we can see that it is now a date object.
So what's really cool
about these functions
is it will take just about
any type of date formatting
you can think of.
So let's say another
example from the cheat sheet
is 13th
of June,
2016.
In this case, we'll say day,
month, and year, run that,
and we get that same date object.
Next, we have a few cool
functions for creating vectors.
We have the sequence function, S E Q
and it's used to create a vector of values
that increment at a regular rate.
So for example, we could
say takes a few arguments.
So from,
to and by.
let's say we want to go from zero to 10
and we want to go by twos.
And when we run that,
we get the values zero,
two, four, six, eight, 10.
If we had put in 0.5 here,
it would also start at
zero and go up to 10
but in increments of 0.5.
Then we have the function R E P or repeat.
And this is used to create a vector
with a repeating set of values.
So we could say, first
argument is called X.
Let's say X is all the
values from one to three.
So remember if you just look at that,
it's just one, two and three.
And so we'll repeat that times equals two.
So that will take this
pattern here, repeat it twice.
So now we get a vector that goes
one, two, three, one, two, three.
If instead of times, however, we say
each equals two,
it will take each individual
element of this vector,
repeat it, and then go
on to the next element.
So now we have one, one,
two, two, three, three.
And finally,
to complete the basic functions.
I'm gonna go over one of
my favorite functions,
which is the grepl function, G R E P L.
And this is used for
finding which elements
of a character vector contain
a particular string of text.
So for example, we could say,
let's say,
so the first argument is the
pattern we're searching for.
So let's say we're searching for
anything that contains this number three
in the character string
and we'll search within
the vector of species vec.
So let's take a look at that.
Look at species vec again,
we have species one,
species three, species two, species three.
Species three and species three
each contain that value
of three inside it.
So we get a return back that
goes false, true, false, true.
If for example, we had said spp now,
or maybe just sp, which of these
contain that string of text
we'll get true for everything
of course and so on.
So common way that I
use the grepl function
is for subsetting data frames or vectors.
So for example, we could say,
if we look at data frame,
this is the data frame we created before.
It has a column of num
vec and species vec.
And if we want to subset
this, let's say grepl,
let's say we want to extract
all of species three,
or all the species that contain,
the species names that
contain the value of three.
We'll say three here,
just like we did before.
And then data frame,
we could have just put in
species vec on its own,
but since we're subsetting
this data frame,
it's better practice
to include a reference
to the column within the data
frame that we're filtering by.
So, again, if we just
take a look at this part,
run that, we get false, true, false, true.
True for species three and species three.
And to filter this data frame,
we also add a comma here
because these are all of
the rows we want to keep,
and we're gonna apply
this to all the columns.
And there it is.
Now we have filtered this data frame
down to just species three.
So that's it for the basic functions.
Now let's continue on with loading data.
I don't have any data sets to
load for this quick tutorial,
but I'll just quickly show
you how these functions work.
Read dot CSV.
All you have to do is put in the path for
the data set you're trying to load.
So actually to make this work
and a little bit nicer for you,
let's actually reverse those functions.
Let's use write dot CSV
to save our special data
frame that we created here,
and then reload it in using read dot CSV.
So we'll just save that
as data frame dot CSV
and the first argument
of the write dot CSV
is the actual data frame.
In this case, we called it data frame
and it will save right
in the base directory
where we are working.
So to get a look at that,
let's go on ahead to
actually another function,
the get working directory,
or getwd.
This will show us where
our base working directory
is located.
Here in my case, it's located in this
user's lukanegoita,
documents, entrepreneurship,
grad ecologists, YouTube
R tutorials folder,
which is actually this folder right here.
Let's say we want to save
it inside this folder here,
which is tutorial scripts.
So I'm just going to add in here,
tutorial scripts slash data frame dot CSV,
and it will save right in here.
There it is.
All right, so now let's
use this read dot CSV
to load it back in.
We have to use this
same file path location,
and we'll save it into a new file,
let's call it data frame uploaded.
Now let's take a look
at data frame uploaded,
and there it is.
Now, interestingly,
it added this extra column
of one, two, three, four
and that's just because
when you use write dot CSV,
it helps to add in row
dot names equals false.
'Cause for some reason,
write dot CSV likes to
add in these row names
whenever you're saving a data frame.
So if we run that again and now load
this data frame one more
time and take a look.
Now we have only those
original two columns
that we had before.
Great.
Now, we have this other function
we haven't talked about,
set working directory.
This is to set where the working
directory is going to be.
In this case, we used
get working directory
to see where it was.
And if we wanted to change
where the working directory is,
we could use that.
However, I include it
here to make a point.
It's a really important and good idea
not to ever use set working directory.
Instead, go to file
new project and create,
oh, let's save that, okay.
New directory or existing directory,
new project, directory name,
create that project
and then start creating scripts in there.
You can see here,
I have a project called
YouTube R tutorials.
The great thing about
using R studio projects
is that it creates that base directory
right where the YouTube R
tutorial's project file is based.
So if we go back one folder
and scroll down here,
you'll see I have this YouTube
R tutorials dot r proj file.
And that's automatically created
when you create a new project in R.
The nice thing about this
is now if I take this
entire folder with the R project in it
and email it to you,
share it with a friend,
send it wherever I wanna send it
and you run this same script,
you will also be able
to load up these data
from this tutorial scripts folder,
because the base directory,
this part, when you use
get working directory,
this part of everything will change
depending on your computer and
where you saved this project.
But YouTube R tutorials,
that base directory
will always be the same
and relative to whoever
is using that project.
So my spiel is done.
Don't you set working directory,
use R project files,
and let's go on from there.
Next, let's create some custom functions.
So up until now,
we've been using functions
that are already created
and built in with R
or other packages that
contain these functions.
But sometimes you just need to
create that perfect function
that fits your job exactly
as you need to do it.
And there's just nothing else out there.
So here we go.
So to create a function,
you use the function function.
Let's name this function, my
func.
And by the way,
if you hear something that
sounds like a dying dog outside,
that is actually a sea
lion, that's not dying.
That's actually quite happy and
roaming around in the water,
defending its territory.
Just wanted to alleviate any anxiety
that that sound might be giving you.
I'm based in the Galapagos
very fortunately.
So, and so there are
random wildlife sounds
that will fill this tutorial as well.
Just a heads up there.
Okay, now back to the, my function.
I'm calling it my func and into that,
we're putting this function function.
The arguments of the function function
are whatever arguments you
want your function to take in.
So we'll just call the
simplest way to do it
is we'll just call it X.
We could've called it whatever we wanted.
So our function will take
in one value that's called X
or one variable that's called X.
And then you use these curly brackets
to enter the contents of the function.
Let's say we want a function
that will modify the value of X
in this weird way.
So we'll create this variable X mod,
and to modify it, to create X mod,
we're gonna take X, add five to it,
and then take the result of
that and multiply it by three.
There's one more thing we
have to add to this function
and that is a return function.
This function tells R
what aspect of the inside of this function
to actually return or output to the user.
In this case, we're going to say X mod.
So looking through this,
we've got this function function
where it will take this value of X,
and then it will take
that value of X add five,
multiply that whole thing by three,
save that as X mod,
and then the function returns
the contents of X mod.
So if we run this, nothing happens,
but the function is now saved here
in our environment under
the functions category.
And so to run this function,
all we have to do is use my func
and now we can use parentheses with it
just like you would
with any other function.
And the first argument that it takes,
the only argument that it takes is X.
And that let's just put in num vec.
And there it is looking at num vec again,
it takes each of these values.
So for example, three,
three plus five is eight
times three is 24,
6 plus five is 11 times
three is 33 and so on.
And it returns to all those values.
And of course, because
this was the only value
in the function
we could have also just
ignored that X equals
and just written it like that
and we would get the same result.
Okay. Now let's move on to a
few miscellaneous functions.
Actually, two of those functions,
we've already gone over up here,
the installed dot packages function
that we use for installing
any new packages
that our computer does not
currently have installed,
but once they are installed,
you do not need to install them again.
You only need to use the library function
to load up those packages
whenever you have a new R session,
I'm going to delete this
'cause this error right here,
actually, I'm gonna comment it out.
There we go. All right.
So that's what the library function does.
You always need to load a new package
into your R working space,
into your new session as it's called
whenever you are working with it again.
If I reloaded R and didn't run this,
I would get an error if I
tried to run these functions,
because it doesn't know where they are.
You can think of it as
install dot packages
is you going to Home Depot
and buying a bunch of new,
really cool fancy tools
and then library is you
going into your shop
and pulling out those tools
and getting them ready to use.
Okay, there's a few other
miscellaneous functions here
that are useful.
There is the help function.
If you ever don't know
what a function does,
just use the help
function on that function.
So let's say, we want
to know what grepl does.
All we have to do is help grepl, run that
and it will automatically open
this little help window here to the right
where we can see all about grep and grepl
and all these other
functions that are related
and what they do and how they work,
the different arguments in them.
And then the best part
that I usually scroll down to immediately,
when I really wanna figure
out how a function works
is the examples section where
you can see concrete examples
in R for how the
particular functions work.
And you can just copy and
paste them right into here
and see what happens.
Another way to access
this help database here
is simply to go to help
in this panel here,
type in the function you're looking for,
hit enter, and it will come up on here.
And then you can search within this page
just by clicking here.
Let's say, we want to look up just grepl,
not grep or anything
else, we got it there.
You can keep scrolling through
and see all the times that that word
occurs in this help file.
Then we have the data function.
This is fun because
we can access a whole
bunch of built-in data sets
for playing around and experimenting in R
as we are learning.
If we run the data function
with empty parentheses,
nothing in it,
we get this list of all
these different data sets
with a short little
description of what they are.
Let's say we want to look at a data set
on the survival of
passengers on the Titanic.
Ooh. Okay.
So notice that the data
set's called Titanic
with a capital T, we can
go here type in Titanic
and run that.
And now, if we look at our environment,
we have this new data set here, Titanic,
and then the values.
For some reason, it says promise here.
I have no idea what that means.
I guess, R is promising
that they're gonna give us the data.
I don't know what that means.
Either way, you can just click
on it and it's right there.
Or if we had run it,
then you could save it as its own file,
My Titanic data.
Doing that also turns it
from saying promise here
to an actual data set.
So if we take a look at,
oh, I guess it's like a weird,
this isn't a good dataset
example, but the point,
'cause it has all these
different components to it.
But anyway, the point is that
you run this data function
with the name of the data set,
and you can extract those data.
You'll notice up here, that's
what I did with trees data.
So I ran data trees,
saved trees as its own data
frame called the trees data.
And that's this right here.
And then I did a few modifications
to add a few columns to it.
I added this column of light
and then use these functions
that I already went over
rep and C to create this vector
of sun and shade treatments.
We run just that.
You can see it's a
vector of sun and shade,
and we're just adding
that into the tree dataset
and then making sun
and shade into a factor
using as dot factor.
So if we take a look at tree data now,
it's the same as before.
And we also have this extra
column of shade and sun values.
You can also learn more about the data
that you've loaded in using
the data function by searching,
by using the help function.
So we'll put Titanic,
or actually let's put trees,
that's more ecological than Titanic data.
We'll put trees into the help function.
And here we have this
really nice explanation
for this tree's dataset,
which explains what these
different columns mean,
how they're measured
and sources or references for
where these data came from.
And a few examples of playing
around with these data.
All right, so that's it for
the miscellaneous functions
and that's it for side one
of the essential functions
of R cheat sheet.
If you liked this video so far
and want to finally feel confident
with visualizing and
managing your own data
in R as an ecologist,
then be sure to check out my online course
on the basics of R for Ecologists.
The course is completely self paced
and I take you by the hand
through all the essentials of
R using ecological datasets,
as well as exercises to test
your learning along the way.
The course is also fully
accessible to everyone,
regardless of financial ability.
So just click below to learn more
and sign up for the
upcoming enrollment period.
Okay, now let's get on to
some basic data visualization.
The most common and basic function
that you'll ever wanna use
for plotting your data in R
is just called plot.
It's great for creating
scatterplots as well as box plots,
as well as a few other things,
but I'm gonna limit the
conversation to that
'cause those are probably
the most common plots
you'll ever need to create.
So let's use our tree data for this.
So the plot function takes an argument,
data equals tree data.
Remember we were just taking
a look at that data set
just before, let's take a
look at it one more time
so I can just show you
what those variables are.
Girth is the diameter of the tree.
Height is the height of the tree.
Volume is the volume.
Girth is in inches.
Height is in feet and volume
is in cubic feet, I believe.
And this is this made
up additional data set
of whether the tree was in
the sun or in the shade.
So if we, so we'll use this data argument
to tell the plot function
that we're gonna be using
in the tree data.
And then all we have to do
is put in the names of the
columns that we want to plot.
And we'll say height, and then
we'll use this tilde symbol,
which can be thought of as,
tilde equals is a function of,
or more simply,
you can just say whatever
is on the left of the tilde, tilde,
is the Y variable
or it's what will appear
on the Y axis.
So here let's have tree
height on the Y axis
and let's do tree volume
on the x-axis.
And when we run this,
we get a nice little plot
of height on the y-axis,
volume on the x-axis, a nice
little simple scatter plot.
We can also create a box plot
if the X variable in this case volume
is a categorical variable.
So let's keep height there.
But instead of volume, let's
look at sun versus shade.
I think we called that column light.
If we run that,
now we get a simple box
plot with sun and shade,
and the box plots created
around those values of height.
The next most essential plotting function
is the hist function
or histogram function.
There's so many times that you want
to just quickly visualize
what your data looked like,
how are they distributed?
What kind of data are you working with?
You just collected those data.
You just came back from
the field, enter them all.
What's the first thing
you're gonna look at?
Gosh, do my data look
reasonable or are they crazy?
Are there some crazy outliers out there?
Let's take a quick look
using the hist function.
Let's just use tree data,
dollar sign height.
That's a capital H I guess.
Let's look at a
distribution of tree heights
in our data set and there it is.
Okay.
Finally, sometimes when we create plots,
we also want to add lines to them.
Let's take a look at this
scatterplot that we had up here.
Plot that one more time,
let's say that we want
to add a line to this,
a best fit line that
shows the relationship
between tree height and tree volume.
Let's say it's a linear relationship
for the sake of simplicity.
Let's create a quick model,
this kind of gets a
little bit more advanced
on the essential functions
of our cheat sheet.
We'll go back to this later,
but let's create a simple model.
We'll call it fitted model
and we'll use the LM function
which stands for linear model.
And this actually takes the same syntax
as the plot function.
Height is a function of volume
and the data are the tree data.
This is going to be our fitted model
and then we're gonna plot these data.
I'm just rearranging the order here.
We're gonna plot this scatter plot,
and then we're going to
use the function abline.
Now remember it with a linear model,
you've got an A coefficient
and a B coefficient.
So for a linear model,
going back to some basic algebra,
Y equals A plus B X,
that is the formula for a linear model.
An AB line means, give
us an A give us a B,
and we will create a line for you.
So the nice thing is that when
we look at this fitted model,
the fitted model returns
these two coefficients,
the intercept, which is the A
and the slope of the volume, which is B.
So if we enter that fitted model
right inside this AB line function
right after we plotted the data,
we have this line that
is thrown right on top.
But sometimes you don't just
want a nice fitted line,
you want to mark certain
thresholds in the data,
but using vertical or horizontal lines.
To do that, still use the abline function,
but we can use V for vertical equals,
so let's say we want a vertical
line at a volume of 40.
So we'll say ABline V equals 40.
And there we have a vertical
line at volume equals 40,
or maybe we'll do ABline
H for horizontal at
height equals 85.
And there we have it.
Now let's move on to
working with data frames.
I just created the stall heading here.
Didn't create it for the other
sections. It doesn't matter.
Let's just start working
with data frames now.
I'm never really sure if data
frames should be one word
or two words,
Word and other applications always tell me
that I spelled data frames wrong.
Wow, look, our studio is telling me
that I spelled data frames
wrong by having them together,
then maybe it is really
just data space frames.
All right.
So the most common function
that I've used when
working with data frames
is just the names function.
And what this does is it
quickly allows us to see
the names of all the
columns in our data frame.
So if we use our original data frame here,
you can see that one
column is called num vec.
Another is called species vec.
If we use the names
function for our tree data,
we have girth, height, volume, and light,
and we can also use the names function
to rename column headings.
So for example, let's index
out just the column of girth.
So that's just the first value of names.
So if we run that, we get just girth
and into that, we're
going to rename it as DBH,
which stands for diameter
at breast height,
which is a fancier way of
saying girth and run that.
And now we take a look at tree data again,
and the first column
name has been renamed.
And if we take a look at the names
for our tree data one more
time by just selecting that
and running that alone,
DBH, height, volume, and light.
I often use it for quickly
looking at the names
of a data frame when I'm trying to refer
or index certain parts of a data frame
and I just forgot what
that column was called.
Next we have the data dot frame function,
which is what we use to
create simple data frames
when we have a bunch of vectors
that we want to bring
together into one data frame.
And if you recall up here,
that's what we did with the
two vectors that we created
when we started
num vec, species vec and
then we use data dot frame
to combine these two
vectors into one data frame.
Now note that both of these vectors
need to be the same
length with one exception,
you can have vectors
that are a length of one.
So for example, let's create a new column
and we'll call it,
My new column.
Cause I'm that original,
equals
let's just say my new column,
we would just want the value
of two inside my new column.
Why not?
When we run that and look at data frame,
we have this new column of twos.
And the reason that worked is because
two in this case is one element.
It's the same as a vector
of just this one element
is evenly divisible into
the number of rows here.
So we get two divided into,
I'm not making any sense.
The point is that two is a length of one
and you can easily fit the two into each.
Okay. You know what?
I can't explain this. Let
me show you another example.
If we had said one comma two,
so now we have a vector
of the value one and two
and run that, it will still work
because now it'll repeat the one and two
throughout this entire data frame.
However, if we had three
values, one, two, and four,
that won't evenly fit
within the available space
of this data frame.
And we'll get an error,
error in data frame,
arguments implied
differing number of rows.
There it is.
So, it usually never have to do this,
but just letting you know
that that's an option.
Maybe I shouldn't have told you.
Next we have,
actually speaking of telling people
more than they need to know,
I'm probably gonna remove data dot frame
from future cheat sheets
from the future versions of
this essential of R cheat sheet,
because there is a far superior way
to make data frames in R,
and those are called tibbles.
So instead of data frame, data dot frame,
let's create our first my
tibble, again, very original.
And here, instead of data frame,
we're going to use the function tibble,
which does the exact same
thing that data dot frame does
creating a data frame,
except the data frame is now
really cool and superior,
and it's not called a data frame anymore,
it's called a Tibble,
or maybe you call it a type of data frame,
Tibble type of data frame.
I don't know.
Anyway, it stands for tidy
table when we run that,
oh, we can't find the function Tibble.
And that's because we have to load up
the package dplyr first
to work with Tibbles.
When we run that, and again,
you can install the package
if you don't have dplyr first.
It stands for data pliers.
So remember you use pliers
for bending and manipulating
and changing things and wrangling things.
And so that's what dplyr is, but for data,
now, we should be able to run this
and take a look at my tibble.
And there it is, we have,
up here it clearly tells
us that it's a tibble.
So thank you very much for that.
It shows us that it is four
rows long by two columns wide.
It shows us the type of data
that each of these columns comprises of.
So here num vec is a
double or numeric column,
species vec is a character column.
And yeah, so it includes all
of this neat information here,
but actually the coolest
thing about Tibbles
is not something we can see
from this really simple dataset.
So let's create a tibble
using our tree data.
My tree tibble. That's what I'll call it.
Now, taking a look at my tree Tibble,
here's the really cool
thing down here it says
with 21 more rows.
Now what's really nice about this
is that if we had just looked
at tree data not as a Tibble,
so the original version of
tree data is not as a Tibble.
Here are the data.
Oh, wait, what are the column names?
We have to scroll up a
bunch to get to here.
Oh, okay. Wow. That's a lot of space.
I don't wanna have to like open this all.
Oh, wait, what happened?
Oh, now I have to, how
do I make, oh, I have,
oh no, there we go, okay.
Yeah, you get my point.
Tibbles are really cool.
There's a bunch of other
advantages to them too,
but for now, I'm just gonna say
they're a neat and simple way to look at
and work with data frames.
So now moving on to the next
function as dot data dot frame,
sometimes you end up working with matrices
and that you want to
convert to a data frame.
So for example,
up here again,
we have,
we use the as dot matrix to convert,
so I'm kind of just going backwards now.
We can take our original data frame,
convert it to a matrix
using as dot matrix.
Don't need to know that function.
I'm just kind of showing you,
trying to create a matrix
here to show you what I mean.
So here we have this
simple matrix of values.
Usually you end up working with matrices
when you're creating
species by site matrices
for multi-variate ordinations
in ecology and community,
when you're dealing with
community data in ecology
and that kind of thing.
So that's usually where you'll
encounter matrices the most.
So let's say we have this matrix here
and we want to convert it to a data frame
use as dot data frame with my matrix.
And there it is back to a data frame
and along the same lines we
also have as underscore Tibble.
And the reason that most of the,
so most of the functions
that come with dplyr
have kind of done away
with using dots or periods
to separate out words in functions
and instead use underscores.
And the reason for that is that
if you're a Python programmer,
the dots actually are
read in a different way
than they are in R.
Where in R they just kind of
become part of the name of the function
whereas in Python, they
actually are an operator
that indicate something a little bit more
than just part of the
name of the function.
And so for that reason to
kind of simplify things
and make them kind of
universally understandable
between the two languages,
that's my understanding.
Maybe someone knows or understands
a better reason for why,
why they've done away with the periods.
So instead of as dot Tibble here
we have as underscore
tibble for this function.
And what this does is it
actually does the same thing as
as dot data frame, as dot data dot frame,
but converts things into a tibble.
So actually up here, we probably should,
instead of using Tibble tree data,
we really should have use as Tibble
'cause that can actually
give you some errors.
But if we use as Tibble,
let's take a look at that.
Here is our tree data tibble.
Okay, now onto as dot matrix,
oh, I guess I am gonna go over that, yep.
So I already did.
As dot matrix is useful when
you want to create species
by site matrices and
some functions require
that you enter matrices into
their arguments rather than,
than data frames.
And so that's what you
would use as dot matrix for.
So again, here is the matrix of values
based on this original
data frame that we had.
So with matrices, sometimes
you need to swap them around.
So swap what is in the column,
make the columns into rows and
make the rows into columns.
And we can do that with the T function.
Or I think that stands for transpose.
Let's see.
T, matrix transpose.
Yes. Okay. I was right.
All right.
So when we run this function on my matrix,
here we have that same matrix,
but the columns and
rows have been reversed.
Then we have the ncol
and the nrow functions,
which is just a quick, useful way
to get how many columns or
rows we have in a data set.
So let's look at our tree data, ncol.
It looks like we have four
columns in the tree data.
Nrow, looks like we have
31 rows in the tree data.
Simple as that, nothing more to it.
So I did mention the tibble
as being quite superior to the data frame
because in what, well,
one of the most useful things is that it
nicely and neatly cuts
off your data frames
so that you can just see
the top 10 entries I guess.
You can also change what that value is.
But either way you see the top few entries
instead of having to scroll
through the whole data set.
But another way to take a look at that
using just typical normal data frame
is using the head function.
And that just returns the top
few entries of a data frame.
So if we'd look at tree data and use head,
I think the default is
six, the top six rows.
So here we see the top
six rows of the tree data.
The reason this isn't as
great as using a tibble
to begin with is it can
be a little bit misleading
if you didn't realize that
you ran the head function.
Cause it doesn't tell you
that there's more rows
in this data frame that are missing.
It's just a quick way to extract
the top little bit of a dataset.
Okay, now I'm going to talk
about one more function
that I use tremendously.
I love it. It's very useful.
There's a lot of ways to use it
and that is the left join function.
Now note, there's also a right join
and a few other types of joins,
which you can learn about
by searching them here.
But I'm just gonna talk about left join,
and then you can figure
out the rest after that.
So what this does is it is
used to combine two data frames
based on a reference column.
And this again also
uses the dplyr package.
So make sure to install and
load that library first.
So let's say,
let's create two data
frames so we can actually
show how this works.
Let's see, let's take a look at tree data.
Let's use it as a tibble.
Let's use the My tree Tibble
since I keep talking about
how great Tibbles are.
We take a look at the tree data.
Okay, let's add a column
that indicates the,
the identity of the tree.
So which tree we're dealing with.
We'll just do that by saying tree ID.
And I think there's 31 rows total. Yeah.
So here we have 10 rows with
21 more. So that's 31 rows.
So into tree ID,
we're just gonna say add in
the values of one through 31
and we'll make this as dot character
just so that it's clear
that these numbers don't
mean anything as a number,
but they're just the
identity of each tree.
Let's take a look at my tree Tibble.
So here we have this new
column now called tree ID.
Okay, and let's say we have,
let's make a new data frame now.
Tree ID
1 through 31.
Let's create it with the Tibble function.
So tree ID is 1 through
31, and then let's see,
let's make up some data.
Tree leaves.
Let's just say we could count
how many leaves each tree has.
I dunno, I'm just making this up again.
Let's just say tree leaves equals let's,
I'm gonna use a few extra functions here
just to make this easy.
So I'll, actually, let's do run if.
So that's picking a random number
from a uniform distribution.
When we type it in, we get
this little window that pops up
that shows us what we can enter in it.
Now I'm not getting that to pop up again.
There we go.
N is the number of values min and max,
so we'll say, N equals 31,
mean equals 3,000,
max equals 5,000 leaves.
Let's say and the problem
is that these values,
if we ran just that, they
give us decimals as well.
So let's just round that to whole numbers.
Since let's just say we can
only count entire leaves
and not partial parts of leaves.
So round,
that should be enough.
Run that,
taking a look at this one more time.
Yup. There we go.
We have these 31 different leaf counts
for these different trees
and we're adding that
as column tree leaves.
So now let's save that as My tree
leaf data.
Taking a look at this,
we have this data set with the tree ID
and the number of leaves for each tree.
And then we have this other data set
that has these other
variables and tree ID,
but doesn't have the leaf data.
So we combine these together
with the left join function.
So typically the first data
set that goes on the left
is the one that has almost
everything already in it.
So here we'll put in my tree Tibble
and then the next data set
is the data set that contains the data
we want to add to it, My tree leaf data.
And then we add in one
more argument that says,
by equals tree ID.
This tells the function,
let's take these data
and then take these data
and add them to these data and match it up
so that every value in this data set
is matched up to this data set
based on a matching tree ID value.
In this case, it's actually the same order
because tree IDs are in the same order.
So let's mix up that order
actually to prove my point.
So I'm just going to index this
and I'm just going to sample
31 values from one through 31
that gives us a random order to everything
and let's save
that into itself.
So now if we take a tree leaf,
we take a look at tree leaf data.
Now all the tree IDs are all mixed up,
but they're still associated
with each particular
number of tree leaves.
So now if we do left join
and let's save this as my data all,
now, if we run left join,
it should connect these
two data sets by tree ID.
Error, can't join because
of incompatible types.
Ah, I know why,
because up here we saved
it as dot character,
but here we did not.
So let's save as dot character,
it's trying to combine
numbers with letters
and that doesn't work,
even though they're both numbers
one of them is a character,
so it doesn't know what to do with that.
Let's do that again.
There we go. No error now.
Let's take a look at my
data all and there it is.
Now we have these tree leaves
attached to this other dataset.
So if we let, let's take
a look at tree ID one.
Tree ID one is 4567,
oh, that's convenient.
That's easy to remember.
4567.
Let's take a look at the
original My tree leaf data.
Oh, look, it's in the top 10.
Number one is 4567.
And so it was able to successfully combine
those two data sets.
Now note that if we didn't include
this by equals tree ID in
here, R is pretty smart.
When we run that,
it shows us joining by equals tree ID
'cause it found that
that is the only column
that's in common between
the two data sets.
If there wasn't a column in common
between the two data sets,
we'd get an error if we did that.
All right, now, let's get onto
the basics of data wrangling.
This is where it gets really
fun and a little more advanced,
but you can do some
really cool things here.
All of these functions are
going to use the dplyr package.
So if you haven't installed
and run the library function
for dplyr, do so now.
And the first first
function we're gonna go over
is the select function.
And this is simply used for filtering
and renaming columns that you want to keep
or remove from a data frame.
Going back to let's use this
new data set that we created
My data all.
So the first argument of these functions
is always the data set
that you want to use.
So in this case, we'll use
the My data all that we created just now,
if we take a look at this,
we've got a bunch of different
columns here, DBH, height,
volume, light, tree ID, and
number of leaves in the tree.
So we can use select to select
which columns we want to keep.
Let's say we're only
interested in DBH and height
and tree ID.
So we can just say DBH, height,
tree ID.
It's that simple.
When we run that function,
now we get a new data frame table
that just consists of
DBH, height and tree ID.
Now we could have also,
let's say we wanted to keep everything,
but we wanted to remove tree volume.
So all we would have to
do is put in a minus sign
and then volume,
just like that.
And now we remove tree
volume from this data frame.
And let's say we wanted to
rename some of the columns
in this data frame.
Let's say tree leads is a little ambiguous
and we wanna rename it to leaf number.
We can just say leaf number equals.
And then that column
was called tree leaves,
actually don't even
need those parentheses,
tree leaves.
So now we only want to remove volume,
but we want to keep everything else
and rename leaf number equals
tree leaves and run that.
Now we have everything
except for volume and leaf
and tree leaves is renamed to leaf number.
Now, if we only included leaf
number equals tree leaves,
that will only select
the column tree leaves
and remove everything else.
Oops, just like that.
So make sure that you
include what you want to keep
or what you want to remove and
then what you want to rename.
So that's what the select function does.
Then we have the filter function.
And what this does
is if select is to filter out
which columns you wanna keep,
the filter function is to filter out
which rows you want to keep.
The first argument again is my data.
And then it's simply a,
any kind of a statement that
generates trues and falses
based on the number of rows that you have.
So we could say,
let's take a look at all the data.
We could say,
say we want to keep all the trees
that had a DBH greater or less than 11.
We want to keep only
these trees in our dataset
that are less than 11.
So we'll create this true
false statement and say,
that's tree DBH.
So we'll say we want to keep
everything where DBH equals
actually is less than 11.
So when we run that.
We're left with just those rows
and you can add multiple
statements on here.
So we could say, we want everything where
DBH is less than 11
and height is greater than or equal to 70.
So when we run that,
now we have only those heights
where the tree is greater than
70 and DBH is less than 11.
And so note that every additional argument
that you add on to the
filter function with a comma
is the same as saying and.
So I want to filter for
everything where this is true
and this is true.
If you want an either or,
instead of a comma,
you can just use this vertical line.
I'm not sure what it's called.
On my keyboard it's right
above the return key
when I hold shift down
and what this says is I
want to filter all my data
where this is true, or this is true.
So when we do that, we
get a whole lot more data.
Next. We have the mutate function.
And this is used to create
new columns in your data frame
or to modify existing ones.
Again, all of these packages,
all of these functions
use the dplyr package.
So once again, first
argument is our data set
and let's say, we want to, right now,
our height is measured in feet,
but let's say we want to
convert our height to meters.
And so to do that, we have to
multiply the height by 0.3048.
That's just the conversion
to convert it to meters.
And so to create a new
column in our data set,
we can name it whatever we want.
So in this case, height, meters equals
and then we'll just say height
times 0.3048.
It's as simple as that.
This new column that we want,
we can name it whatever we want,
equals height times whatever.
So now if we take a look at
our data height in meters,
we have it right here.
And so if we want it to add
a few different new columns,
we can just hit a comma.
And let's say, we want to do height in,
we'll just call it height modified.
And it'll be a height times
0.05, whatever that means.
We can also hit return
here because R is not line
or space sensitive for
certain things like this,
to keep it a little bit more neat.
I can hit return there.
So then here we can clearly see
what all the different columns
that we're creating are.
And if we run this, now we
have two additional columns,
height meters and height
mod that have been added on.
And you can also modify the existing ones.
Like let's say,
let's say we don't want to rename height,
but we just want to modify it
so that its height in meters.
I'm gonna remove this.
For simplicity, I'm just
gonna call that height.
So now what it's gonna
do is it's gonna say
in this column height,
we're going to take height
and multiply it by that.
But because height is the same
name as the existing column,
it will just replace the original values
with these new ones.
So now if we take a look under height,
height has already been
converted to meters in this case.
Okay. Moving on.
We're going to use the summarize function.
So this summarizes all
the different columns
in your data frame.
If we put in the, my data all again here,
we have to enter in what
summary values do we want.
So for example, maybe we want
to find out the mean height
and we'll call that,
and mean height will be
based on the mean height.
So applying the,
applying the function mean,
which I'll go over in a little
bit to the column height.
And then let's say we also
want to know the maximum girth
or maximum DBH, and we'll
use the function max,
which we'll also go over in a bit later,
but it's pretty self-explanatory.
So now, if we run this,
you simply get this table with
mean height and maximum DBH.
Now you might wonder
if you're just creating summary
values for all the columns
why create a table
if there's only going to be
one row of these summary values
in this case, the mean
height and the maximum DBH.
And that's because
summarize can be combined
with the group by function,
which is really neat.
And the group by function
allows us to split the data set
into individual groups.
For example, let's say group by,
let's group the data into
whether the trees were in the sun
or the shade.
So we'll just use group by,
first argument's the data again.
And we'll just say, we
want to group by light.
That's the name of that column?
Oops!
So if we run that you'll
notice nothing really changes.
It's the same data set,
but up here we have this
thing that says groups,
light,
and the two tells us that
there's two different groups.
In this case, there is just shade or light
or shade or sun or whatever it was.
So on its own, it doesn't really do much.
But then if we take this grouped data
and put it inside of
this summarized function,
so I'm just gonna copy this over again,
copy that.
And in place of my data all,
I'm gonna put in this group by function.
So now my data all has been grouped
and then we're putting it
into this summarize function.
And now take a look
and now we have one row for
each of the different groups
that we had grouped the data by.
So now we have the mean
height for shade trees.
We have the mean height for sun trees
and the maximum DBH for
shade trees and sun trees.
And when you use the summarize function
with the group by function,
it actually automatically
removes the grouping afterwards.
So you'll notice here,
there's no remaining grouping in the data,
but sometimes it's useful to ungroup
with the data to make sure that
something doesn't go wrong down the line.
So for example,
we could have grouped by my data group.
So I'm just saving this
data set, this data frame,
as its own new data frame that's grouped.
Oops, well that grouped.
If we take a look at this same data frame,
but up here, we've got this indication
that it's grouped by light.
And then we can put that
into summarize and run that.
And so here is the data set
or the summary of that
data set based on light,
but then we might want to do
something else with these data
and we want to ungroup them
'cause they're still grouped.
So we'll put them in this
ungroup and when you run that,
oops, it's the same data set again,
but you'll notice the grouping
variables have disappeared.
And you can also use the group by function
with the filter and mutate.
So for example, if you
want to filter for all,
if you want to remove or
extract only the tallest trees
from the sun group and the shade group,
if you just used max height.
So which height equals
max height in this filter,
you'd only get one tree value
because it's the maximum,
the tree with the tallest height
out of the whole data set.
But if you group the
data first based on light
and applied this filter,
it would actually extract,
it would extract the tallest
tree from each of the groups
that you had grouped by.
So the group by function can
be really, really useful.
All right, we are almost done.
And actually we've covered
most of the functions
in this last section on basic statistics,
but I'll quickly go
over them one more time.
We've got the LM or linear model function.
This is the most basic function
for doing any kind of
statistical analysis in R.
It allows you to do everything from T test
to a nova regression, multiple
regression, et cetera.
They all fall in that same
category of simple linear models.
And so a simple way,
simple example of this would
be let's do a linear model
of DBH
is a function of,
so remember this tilde
indicates is a function of,
what's on left of it is the Y variable,
and on the right of it
are the X variables.
So let's say we want to model
DBH as a function of light.
So the sunlight,
and what else do we have to work with?
As function of sunlight
and the number of leaves.
So remember leaves were just random.
We just created this random data set.
So tree leaves shouldn't
actually really be
an important predictor of DBH,
but let's just see what happens.
So,
a simple model would be just
how is DBH a function of light?
And then we add the data in here,
my data all.
So this would be the
simplest way to do this.
And since light is two
different categories,
you can kind of think of this as a T test.
Is there a difference in DBH
between these two different variables?
And we'll save this as mod one.
And so we take a look at mod one.
It doesn't really give
us much to work with.
It just gives us the
estimate for the coefficients
in this model,
but the summary function,
not to be confused with the
summarize function from before,
just summary will give us
a more detailed summary
of these model results.
So here we have the model
formula, the residuals,
the coefficients, and then the P value,
whether the intercept and
the slope in this case,
the effect of light is significant
and a few other test
statistics and information,.
And you should check out my other video
on doing basic linear regression in R
if you're interested in learning
more about how this works.
I'm not going to go over the details now,
just want to show you
how to use this function.
Now we could have also added
in some more variables.
So for example, we'll add in,
so let's say we think tree leaves
are also a predictor of DBH.
It might actually be the other way around,
but either way, let's run that
and now take a look at the summary.
And we have the same results as before
with sunlight appearing to be significant,
but then tree leaves do not
have a significant effect
or association with DBH in this case.
Now there's a lot of assumptions to this
because it's a linear model,
but again, I'm not going
over any of the stats here
just wanted to show you how this works.
Then we have the mean function
which we've gone over already.
I think I used it a bunch of times.
It just calculates the
mean value from a vector.
So if we use num vec here,
the mean value of num
vec happens to be five.
And if we have an NA value,
we can't actually calculate the mean,
cause it will just give us an NA,
so remember you can also use
NA dot RM or NA dot remove
equals true
and then it will calculate the
mean after removing the NA.
Then we have max and min.
Let's actually use our data here.
So let's see what the maximum
height is,
87 feet.
Let's see.
And then we have the minimum,
the minimum tree height is 63 feet.
And so on.
Then we also have median,
which is different from mean,
'cause it gives us the value
where 50% of the data are below that value
and the other 50% are above
that value in the data set.
So our median value in this case
with tree heights
is 76.
If we did our mean value, it
might be close to the median,
but there are cases where
the median is more important
or more informative than
the mean and vice versa,
but let's just, out of curiosity sake,
let's see what the mean value
of tree Heights is, is also 76.
All right, well that makes sense.
Given enough data that fall
under normal distribution,
the mean and median
should be the same thing.
And finally, last but not least,
the function that I think
is quite underrated.
Very few people ever mention it,
but I just love this function
'cause it's a really quick
way to get a nice summary
of any categorical variables
that you have in your data.
And that is the table function.
So in our dataset here that
we've been working with,
let's say we want to get a quick summary
of how many trees were in the shade
and how many trees were in the sun.
We'll just apply this table
function with my data all
to light.
And we have this quick
output that shows us
15 trees were in the shade
and 16 trees were in the sun.
And if you have a more
complex categorical variables
such as maybe you have a
column for different species
and you're dealing with
hundreds of different species,
maybe even just tens of different species,
but you have a huge data set
and you just wanna see
how many data points
do you have available for each species.
Then you would run that
and you'd get this nice little table
of the different species names
and how many individual
observations you have for each.
So that is it, that
concludes the functions
that I covered in my essential
functions of R cheat sheet.
Hey, I hope you enjoyed this tutorial.
If you did, make sure to click
the like button down below,
it really helps me be
able to share my videos
as much as I can get them out there,
get as many people to
see them as possible.
Be sure to subscribe if
you wanna get more updates
whenever I post new videos.
And again, if you really liked this
and want to kind of
take it a step further,
be sure to check out my course
on The Basics of R for Ecologists.
There's a link down
below in the description,
and you can subscribe right there
to find out when the next
course enrollment opens up.
So with that, I hope you have
a great rest of your day,
and see you next time.
(bright upbeat music)